let's start with what's more likely to
happen who's more likely to fall out of
that first round bye this weekend the
new england patriots or the green bay
packers well i'm going with the green
bay packers there i mean this is the new
england patriots and they're kind of
special and they know how to win these
type of games in this type of situation
it's the miami dolphins coming up to the
northeast on a sunday afternoon and i
don't think that bodes well now listen i
don't necessarily look at the lions or
anything like that and think oh yeah
they're going to beat green bay but i
guess i think there's more of a chance
of that happening than the other one for
sure yes i i do i just can't see new
england blowing this opportunity at home
this time of the year they don't do that
yeah i agree with this 16 point
favorites over miami and it's one thing
to to maybe trip over your own shoelaces
like they've done in past years remember
the two consecutive division losses on
the road in 2015 that forced the
patriots to go to denver in the afc
championship game they still had a buy
locked up there's a huge difference
between a buy and playing in the wild
card round the patriots haven't played
in the wild card round since
2009 that's not about to happen and and
the competition not nearly as stiff as
it is for the packers in the nfc so i
agree with you the new england patriots
or the packers more likely to fall out
of a first round by the patriots more
likely to earn it and not play until the
divisional round all right what's more
likely christian mccaffrey gets his 1
000 rushing yard 1000 receiving yard
season he'll be only the third all time
to do that or jameis winston becomes the
first ever to throw 30 touchdown passes
and 30 interceptions well this is a good
one here um
i guess more likely is christian
mccaffrey i think there's a very good
chance both of these happen i mean i do
i mean jameis winston throwing two
interceptions is you know just a normal
day in the park uh but it is atlanta
and they're kind of simple on defense so
i guess i i do i i edge on more on
christian mccaffrey 67 yards receiving
the football with a team that's not
playing for anything norv turner very
smart you know this is not only about
you know this is
on north turner's resume uh let alone
this is a special thing in the lures of
the nfl history so i think they do their
best to get mccaffrey the ball and get
the 67 yards receiving
roger craig marshall faulk the only
other ones to ever do it and and it's
not all that difficult to engineer a
short pass it's essentially a handoff
right you can you can come up with 67
receiving yards fairly easily if you're
determined to do it and that's really
all the panthers are playing for and i
don't know that they really care to win
as evidenced by the fact that they're
starting will grier at quarterback again
all due respect i think david tepper is
smart enough to understand that five and
eleven's a lot better than six and ten
for draft position and uh and look the
same it's not like the saints i have
nothing to play for the saints still
very much alive for a buy as well so i
think the panthers are going to lose but
i also think mccaffrey is more likely to
get his 67 receiving yards the falcons
only have 10 interceptions all year
which uh yeah it might make it harder
for jamis to to accomplish something he
clearly doesn't that's the difference
jameis clearly doesn't want his
mccaffrey clearly does want his which
makes his more likely all right next
topic what's more likely ryan tannehill
continues his career resurgence at
houston or tannehill turns back into a
pumpkin against the texans defense well
i'm going career resurgence here all the
way i mean there's nothing to at this
point to even make me think otherwise
with bryan tannehill i mean even in the
two losses he played really well i mean
again last week there they were up early
against the saints then they got down
kind of big and there it was 31-28 in
the middle of the fourth quarter and
you're going wow tennessee's recaptured
all the momentum and the saints are in
trouble ryan tannehill throws a strike
on the post route the guy gets hit as
he's catching the ball fumbles and the
game was never the same and that was it
for that but uh i i think ryan tannehill
is just feeling it he's kind of showing
everybody what kind of player he is and
they kind of got some mojo on the
offensive side of the ball i think he
continues his his career resurgent plus
houston
it's kind of an unmotivating
circumstance of games for them too to
where
you know these are the kind of games you
don't know who's going to show up uh as
far as what team and are they going to
take it real seriously down in houston
and and here's the thing you know the
nfl has done the best job it possibly
can to ensure that the games that that
are interconnected are being played at
the same time but but the texans will
know before kickoff whether or not they
have anything to gain in the afc playoff
tree right because the chiefs will have
lost which opens the door for the the
texans to move from four to three and
avoid playing the bills in the wild card
round which i think is very important or
it won't matter if the chiefs beat the
chargers in the one o'clock window then
when the 4 25 pm eastern window rolls
around the texans will know whether or
not to put deshaun watson anywhere near
the field and and that that will help
the titans and hurt the texans keep this
fact in mind though the titans have not
won in houston since 2011 when they won
23-22
uh on the first day of january 2012. now
there's only two guys still on the team
jerrell casey and brett kern but the
titans have historically not done well
back in the town they used to call home
when they were the houston oilers does
that factor in any way for you into this
possibility of the titans going in and
winning no it does not it does not
factor at all you know i i think you
know i just look at derek henry's health
tennessee having to play you know having
to a must-win situation and houston
having really nothing to play for
like you said i don't know i mean if
you're houston
even if kansas city does lose the game
do you want to play tennessee again the
next week do you want to play buffalo i
don't even know the answer to that but
but you would but if you beat tennessee
you're most likely not going to see
tennessee right well you're going to go
to the free seat and the 16's more
likely to be the steelers right right
yes yes right as long as pittsburgh
doesn't lose you're exactly right yes we
came into the season thinking that
the titans would have a decision to make
with marcus mariota franchise tag
transition tag signing a new contract
whatever now they have that decision to
make about ryan tannehill the decision
with mariota is already made see you
later marcus what are they going to do
with tannehill i i think you ride with
them you go with marine tannehill
for my money from what we've seen
i mean again tennessee they're going to
be what right now in the draft somewhere
between 16 and 20 you know maybe higher
we don't know
they're you know it's going to be hard
to get like a big difference making
franchise quarterback maybe if they want
to draft a quarterback you know in the
second round do something like that uh
but i think you go with ryan tannehill
almost maybe something like it you know
like we talked about with the jameis
winston contract a two-year deal
where maybe you can get out of it you
know in a good place after one year if
you don't like it that way whatever it
may be
but i think you do go with ryan tanner
ryan tannehill again as you and i have
known for a few years it's been much
better than what we all perceive it to
be when he's healthy and when he was
playing down in miami i challenge
anybody go down look at his win loss
record his stats anything like that it's
much more impressive than i was ever
aware of right i know we had a friend
last year that kind of pointed it out to
us and then you dug into the stats a
little bit and like the the true facts
of the matter and you went like man yeah
it really has been a lot of good
stretches in miami but the injuries were
the issue him not being able to play in
that playoff game because of an injury
it's all led to the perceived notion
that he's maybe not as good as he really
is and i think he's kind of showing
people this year what he's all about
and and if the titans don't find a way
to keep him off the market it gets very
interesting i think there would be
greater interest by other teams yes in
tannehill than there would be in jameis
i agree both guys are available a
hundred percent you could trust ryan
tannehill as we've seen i mean he
doesn't turn the ball over he's a good
athlete he's a top-notch you know
accurate thrower of the football and a
really good arm too again it's not aaron
rodgers or mar holmes or deshawn watson
or an arm like that but it's still
really good and how many times over the
last month or so have we gone whoa 40
yard throw on them on the dime you know
50-yard throw bulls-eye 55-yard throw
bulls-eye i mean he's showing that he
there's a reason he was a top-ten pick
in the draft that there's some traits
about his play that is franchise ish
right and uh
i think if you're the tennessee titans
you go who else is out there this is the
guy he's done a lot of good for us let's
go with him
i've been trying to gently nudge the
horse toward the water so you would come
to the conclusion on your own but what
i've been trying to suggest is your old
coach john gruden may make a beeline for
ryan tannehill uh you know
he would be his type of guy there there
would certainly be some things there you
know i think the biggest thing would
like yeah gruden would love ryan
tannehill's athleticism you know that's
that's thing with tannehill was was
recruited to texas a m to play wide
receiver in the sec
you know that means you're running four
or five and you're you're some sort of
athlete to be doing that and that's what
he is and he's shown us not only with
his big arm here over this stretch but
he can rip off a 20 and 30 yard run when
he has to too
yeah and look the titans i think may
have to franchise tagging to keep him
off the market i think they're going to
catch wind of other teams that have real
interest in him and i think your guy
john gruden would i think there are
anybody who's looking for a starting
quarterback has to think about tan hill
there are some things to be concerned
about right but he addressed a lot of
those those questions so far this year
you're you're in the you're in the boat
that the oakland raiders are definitely
moving on from derek carr i'm going to
be trying to find somebody you are 100
yes yeah and and look maybe they can't
find anybody and they just stick with
derek carr but they don't have to make
the same kind of huge financial decision
early there's a couple million that
becomes fully guaranteed in february uh
so yeah who cares right
you you'll have offset language in that
and you'll make that money back if he
goes somewhere else as a backup i i
think they're going to check every
possible option i don't think they're
going to go the draft you know john
gruden's not a guy that wants to groom a
rookie he wants a a savvy and sage and
experienced veteran that he can turn
into another rich ganon yeah and i think
tannehill would be the best candidate
for that yeah well i i do think there is
uh some true positives about ryan
tannehill what he can be there's no
doubt yeah i guess i'm still a little
bit in the air with the derek carr thing
just like i still feel like it's 50 50.
i have no inside knowledge of that or
anything like that uh i guess if you
made me like go okay chris you got to
bet if derek carr is going to be on the
raiders next year or not i'm i think i
probably lean towards more of what
you're saying like 55
he won't be there 45
he will be there you know the big
question again is right like what who's
there to be had uh and i think there's
certain quarterbacks that john gruden
only has like an eye towards you know he
wants that
electric athletic
he can move around and do stuff like
that when when there's nobody open and
my plays didn't get anybody open in the
pass game i want a guy who can get me
out of jail as far as making a play
extending a play running scrambling
throwing on the run doing all those
things and
that's going to be the big thing who is
that guy and may you maybe you're right
mike tannehill might be the closest
thing to that this year on the market if
he if he does get on the market
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports